[Applause]
i don't remember uh audience but a
couple weeks ago
there was a genuine ad uh on the
internet uh on one of those you know
listings things
and it was looking it was basically
making a porn film
uh using a sarah palin lookalike there's
an update ladies and gentlemen
such is the the highest standard of porn
the film has been made already
and uh this week uh there are on the web
there's a website that claims to have
the script and it's full of gems there's
something
couldn't we mean no no wait
here is a scene now this is it it's
quite innocent
uh so she's called sarah
sarah can you be sarah what are you
saying like that
what like she's backward what do you
mean
it's not written you've changed your
name for legacy
yeah sorry i'm sorry yeah
you're the business partner
okay so uh i'll just read it i'll read
the stage directions
sarah sits across them she's holding a
much bigger part than me i'm not doing
this
you've got loads loads uh so sarah's
sitting together
she's holding a brochure for the latest
snowmobile model go
uh what do you say handsome how about
you and me
take one of these babies out for a test
drive yeah i'd love to sarah
but with your husband out of town i'm
afraid i just feel a little funny about
it
[Applause]
i mean after all the man's my business
partner
oh for criminy's sake why don't you take
your nuts out of your little gucci purse
grab your
noodle and act like a man
this is this is great listen to my line
i don't know
stage direction sarah unbuttons her
blouse we'll take that as red
well before you and your boyfriend lance
bass head off to the next
clay aiken concert why don't you feast
your eyes on
mama's jugs she
she lifts her skirt and starts rubbing
herself through her panties
[Applause]
a bit tight yeah leave it without again
that's red
it's time to drill baby drill hard and
drill deep
what are you waiting for congressional
approval
i will not work with monkeys at all ever
again because
if they get frustrated for instance then
they'll
disappear up into the rafters and
start pulling this set apart and
masturbating
why are you laughing it's the truth
and that monkey that you saw on that
picture
that one i know you have it again but
yeah that one you little
[__]
[Applause]
is you there you know what he's doing
he's actually he's wearing a fur bikini
because he's got a perpetual erection
they put a little bit of fake yeah they
had to build him a little fur bikini to
put on
there it is
he would get ticked off and what he was
doing he's
you know he pulled part of the hair
piece off
and i thought well that's no good
and then he got really angry with me and
he climbed up and went and had a wank
somewhere
that's all good actors do yeah
hi stand up you all right now uh what
what's your question
other people will be asking questions
um also played in the hard to hard pilot
movie was wanted in the for a bigger
part within the series
are you a real person
[Applause]
we've gone to central casting i said we
need a german fan
i've got just the woman for you so what
was it jilts and john was it in an
episode
and now um i heard that she was in the
pilot movie
and i heard that she was wanted um to
play jennifer's sister and i wanted to
know who came up with this idea and why
it was dropped
okay did she say something about my part
no who dropped it
no it was uh just that john was was she
ever going to play your sister
in the show no i don't think it's not me
curious yeah okay yeah the answer is no
a lot of people traveled a long way to
here no
can we meet our first uh bodyguard
please
hello oh oh
i'm sensing you know her okay what's
your name
laura the tie is askew and
it won't do you'd never ever get close
to me with that
oh i think she's trying to be sexy
bodyguard okay laura oh look at you
working it
okay all right laura hope you get your
trumpet
okay laura we're counting down three two
one throw
what is this happening i wouldn't mind a
shout out the title what
do you want to do it yeah
what kind of paint is that it's a
water-based paint can i get it off
i douse this wait do you want to do it
yeah i want to do it where is he
oh
i have every confidence in you
maybe i stand on something back here you
have a platform there or something okay
you just
stand in the back there between the
flags okay is this okay perfect how does
that look okay is that a long lady
monica lewinsky
[Applause]
did you bring a speech with you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
for attending this press conference i'll
take your
your uh your questions in a minute i
just wanted to run over a few items
first of all
[Music]
this is a book there's a book called
shop horror right and it's a collection
of all these terrible
shop names in britain and there are
quite a lot of good uh hairdressing one
here's a good hair you like this one
there it is curling you softly
that sounds like having a [__]
[Applause]
is another hairdressing one do you see
they've traveled
blonde dye bleach
do you get it you get it did you get it
was that in was that in sydney
blonde eye beach the shop shop look at
that shop
mary
[__] in there
you can't do this in america
okay imagine you're opening a fruit and
veg shop
and you're prone to depression okay what
might you call it uh
this is good prone to depression you're
under depression and you're opening a
fruit and vegetable
no no guesses oh hang on the house give
us a bit longer
can't we literally people are watching
us sit here and think of puns
veggies vegetables down in the somewhere
you'll never get it you'll never get it
melon colony
[Applause]
uh she says in the u.s we call it a
pickup line
whatever where are you oh there she is
hello hi hello uh is your husband here
no he isn't he's back in the mirror my
daughter is here angie
great i don't care
[Applause]
if he wanted to know that's her daughter
i didn't and
her favorite channel blind is actually
oh this is hard with your daughter right
there
is that a mirror in your pocket cause i
can sure see myself in your pants
she adds i know this is not a great way
to start a chat but i was pretty easy in
the 80s
i love the daughter clapping yay
and that's why i'm here yay
[Music]
uh haley murray uh a lot of
joke is your partner here no
oh that's hiding oh he you said this to
her
i can't believe you said this to her
your eyes are like spanners
every time i look into them my nuts
tighten
now melody caviar smith melody
melody hello melody hi
did someone say this to you no no no i
heard
in passing and it just made me giggle i
bet it would
i used to right i used to hate donkeys
until i checked out your ass
i can only eo when well now since both
of you
are fluent in french right and what
we're going to do is we're going to get
a few of those chat up lines and see if
they sound better
in a sort of french art house setting i
think you'll enjoy it involves no nudity
[Applause]
no no no
i didn't know it was that silly this
program
is
[Music]
[Applause]
you